first on CBS this morning a new report
warns about a big increase in data
breaches affecting tens of millions of
Americans the Identity Theft Resource
Center counted nearly 1,500 breaches of
US private and government organizations
in 2019 now that's up 17 percent from
their tally the year before researchers
estimate about 165 million sensitive
records were exposed our consumer
investigative correspondent that's Anna
Warner is here and shows us a rising
number of ways that thieves are trying
to steal our information Anna that's not
good good morning would you learn good
morning well Gail you know industry
experts say surprise companies are still
not doing enough to protect your data
you and I may not remember this but in
2018 the group says the total number of
data breaches actually dropped but now
they say it was a blip which means more
people may face the experience of one
Detroit resident we spoke to I got a
letter in the mail from Barclays Bank
and the letter said that my line of
credit application was denied
Jaspreet Singh says he hadn't filed for
that line of credit or the parade of
false loan applications that followed as
crooks using his personal information
tried over and over to run their scams
in 20 18 and 19 finally charging his
business MasterCard for $4,500
MasterCard told me that I had requested
a new credit card which I never did and
that they sent a credit card to somebody
in Texas I believe and so this $4,500
worth of charges were from somebody in
Texas who are using my business credit
card to run Facebook ads for their
business Singh says his private
information was exposed with millions of
others in the 2017 Equifax hack and odds
are more people will face similar
problems in its 2019 end of year data
breach report the Identity Theft
Resource Center says the number of data
breaches went up 17% the group says one
significant new threat that emerged
consumers or company
data being exposed through databases
left unsecured they say a number of
large organizations simply failed to add
a password to protect their cloud-based
data it's not known if that data was
then stolen another trend that's
exploded in the past year they say
something called credential stuffing
where hackers buy someone's stolen login
and password from the dark web then see
if that same combo gets them into other
online accounts the center's CEO Oh
James Lee the reason it's so easy is
because so many of us use the same
password for multiple accounts the
report says noteworthy credential
stuffing attacks in 2019 included Intuit
Boost Mobile Duncan and the streaming
service Disney Plus Singh says the
experience was a good learning lesson
despite having to fight the identity
thieves for more than a year I try to
stay happy I try to find the good and
everything because you can't change what
happens but you can change how you react
to it well Singh says his credit card
company did reimburse his card
eventually for the $4,500 in fraudulent
charges he also had to put a freeze on
his credit with all three credit bureaus
and flagged the problem to all of his
banks and now he's concerned because now
people know his doughnut choices cream
what else can we do to protect our data
you know so here's the thing we keep
saying this right please please don't
use the same login and like 20 different
accounts oh you know I cringe when you
say that because I you know that
credential stuffing they take that and
they go hey you know what I bet I can
use that on Tony's you know Capital One
and is Wells Fargo or is chaser or
whatever you know bank you're using so
you really don't want to use that you
want to contact your banks you want to
place those freezes on your credit if
you're a victim of identity theft report
it to law enforcement but it's a lot of
work so try to avoid it in the first
yeah but it's a lot more work on the
other side yeah but who knew there was
an identity theft Resource Center yes
thank you
and they will help you can resources at
their website very good to know Anna
thank you very much